around educational and Eve is a field  agent she's very capable to kind of sees  herself as bonds equal she's not but  that's how she sees herself  like most people in England I grew up  with them and I think they're amazing  films i've always loved them so i just  can't believe that I was part of all of  this and I still can't believe it you're  gonna have it on automatic first I've  been training for like two months now  right I've mainly been doing guns  machine guns and handguns in particular  Walther PPK I'm just so excited to be  part of this whole journey and it's a  long journey because seven months shoot  it's the longest from that I've ever  been part of but I'm just ready to ride  the roller coaster  you